الينا الان من بيروت امين قموري الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي اهلا بك سيد امين اختيال
القائد الميداني في حزب الله وسام طويل
برايك اللا اين سياخذ الامور بين حزب الله
واسرائيل في هذه
المرحله يعني من الواضح ان نتنياهو الذي
يواجه ازمه داخليه قويه جدا يريد نقل
المعركه الى مكان اخر يعني طبعا بهدف اولا
الضغط على الدبلوماسيين الذين يجرون مف
ضات من اجل لملمه الوضع في شمال لبنان او
فعلا جر الامريكيين الى معركه مفتوحه مع
الجانب اللبناني يعني منذ فتره وحتى اليوم
الحدود اللبنانيه تخطت كل القواعد
الاشتباك التي كانت قائمه في السابق نحن
امام حرب حقيقيه لها ديناميتها الخاصه وان
كانت لم تصل بعد الى مستوى الحرب الشامله
عمليات القطف تجاوزت المناطق الحدوديه الى
العمق الداخلي في لبنان في الم قابل ايضا
ردود حزب الله ايضا تجاوزت المنطقه
الحدوديه المباشره في الاراضي المحتله الى
العمق وخصوصا عندما وصلت الى قاعده ميرون
العسكريه يعني عمليات النزوح كبيره في
الجانبين في الجانب اللبناني هناك عمليات
اخلاء للمنازل في القرى الحدوديه وفي
المقابل ايضا اكثر من 80 ال مستوطن تركوا
بيوتهم منذ ثلاثه اشهر او اربع اشهر الى
الداخل الاسرائيلي وباتوا يشكلون ع على
القياده العسكريه بطبيعه الحال يعني يدرك
الجميع ان عمليه اغتيال بهذا المستوى مثل
عمليه اغتيال عاروري في قلب الضاحيه
الجنوبيه معقل حزب الله كانت برد اولي
باستهداف الميرون حسما حزب الله
عندما يسقط مسؤول
كبير في صفوفه الميدانيه حتما حتما لا
يمكن الا ان يرد وسبق للامين العام وان
اكد من اي عمليه اتيال سيرد بمثلها
فبالتالي يعني ولاسباب
عده سيحاول قدر الامكان الرد وان كان
القرار العام لدى الحزب حتى هذه اللحظه هو
بان يبقى جبهه اسناد وان لا تكون جبهه
مفتوحه يعني اذا دققنا النظر فيما يجري في
المنطقه نرى ان الجبهه اللبنانيه هناك
اربعه اطراف معنيين بها الجانب الامريكي
الذي لا يريد حرب شامله الجانب الايراني
الذي لا يريد ايضا حرب شامله او الانجرار
اليها حزب الله وهو طرف اساسي وله خصوصيته
فايضا يعني لو كان يريد الحرب الشامله ل
دخل بها منذ قبل اربعه اشهر اي واما الطرف
الرابع وهو نتنياهو الذي يريد توريط
الامريكيين معه في معركه كبيره من هذا
النوع نظرا لاسباب لاسباب عده منها وضعه
الشخصي ووضع ال العام في داخل اسرائيل هل
تنجح هذه المحاوله علينا ان ننتظر قليلا
لكن باعتقادي ان حزب الله سيحول